-We had a great thing happen
one time when we had lunch.
We were standing in
the street talking.
-Oh, are you kidding me?
Best day of my life.
-Yeah.
We were standing in the street
talking, and we're both,
you know -- we're both
television personalities.
We've --
You're a film maker.
You're a very
well-known comedian.
We were standing on the street,
and not a single person stopped.
-No one said hello.
-And then, who did we see?
-You would think that would be
some kind of spectacle.
These two guys.
-Nothing.
-And we were working it.
We were standing there for
a full ten minutes talking.
And then Bradley Cooper
showed up.
-Bradley Cooper showed up.
The Bradley Cooper.
-And I was thrilled,
because I went to college
at the same time and at the
same college as Bradley Cooper.
I was in the improv group.
He was in the nomadic
theatre company,
but I never met him.
We never crossed paths.
We were at parties and things.
He was famously good-looking.
-Oh, gotcha.
That didn't develop
later in life?
[ Laughter ]
-No, but you really have
to be so good looking
to be good looking in --
like, famously good looking
in college.
-Oh, I see what you mean.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Like, in other words,
you can be, like,
he's sexiest man alive,
but you can pull that con over
on a "people,"
but not on your English class,
you know what I mean?
You really have
to sell it local.
And he had it!
Like, he really --
People would be like,
"Have you ever seen
Bradley Cooper?"
We never met, and then here
we are in the street,
and you know Bradley,
and you introduced me to him.
And I said, "Hey, I was in
the improv group you went to --
you were in the
other theater group."
And he just goes, "All right."
And I was like, that's a --
That's a letdown, but --
But in retrospect,
I blame you, because...
[ Laughter ]
-...well, because of
the introduction.
I feel like on this show,
you do such a nice job.
This next guy is a filmmaker,
he did "Sleepwalk with Me,"
and he did the thing --
got a new tour,
please welcome Mike Birbiglia.
You didn't do that.
You just go,
[ mumbling ] "Mike Birbiglia,"
and I feel like you
could have gone big!
You could have been like,
"This guy,
he's a very small part
in 'Train Wreck,'
he is the 75th lead on
'Orange is the New Black,'
he was on one episode
of 'Girls,'
please welcome
Mike Birbiglia, everybody."
Nice to meet you.
He'd be like, "Oh, wow."
-Yeah, I should have given you
a talk-show introduction.
Do you remember, the other thing
that I remember happening is
after no one, not
a single person noticed us...
-Yes.
-...a very beautiful woman
walked by and, like,
saw Bradley Cooper
and went into like --
Yeah, it was an Irish woman.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It was like "The Matrix"
where everything got
really slow.
She was like --
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's wild.
He is astoundingly beautiful.
-Yeah, he really is.
And then we, like, had lunch,
and just ate in silence.
-Well, that lunch --
That lunch was very memorable
for me because I was writing
this movie I made called
"Don't Think Twice."
-A fantastic film.
-Oh, thanks!
It's about --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks.
If you're not familiar,
it's a film about sort of
a group of best friends
in an improv group,
and someone gets cast in sort of
a "Saturday Night Live"
type show, sort of
a doppelganger "SNL"
with a doppelganger
Lorne Michaels.
I was terrified at the time that
we were just going to get sued
by "SNL" and Lorne Michaels,
and so then when we went
to lunch, I thought here is a
great opportunity to talk to
the person who is
my Lorne Michaels,
and that's you.
-Oh.
[ Crowd aws ]
-Although, I don't know --
-No, I don't know.
No, I mean -- No, it is.
I mean, like -- I wouldn't know
how to call Lorne.
So I talked to you
to get a vibe on it,
so I pitched you the movie.
You gave me nothing.
-Yep.
-And when I say nothing,
I mean precisely nothing.
Like, you didn't go positive.
You didn't go negative.
You just go, "Hmmm."
I go, "It's a movie about this,
blah, blah, blah."
And you go, "All right."
-Yeah.
-And then when we were leaving,
when I was dropping you off
at your apartment, I go,
"Hey, what do you think?
Do you think Lorne would be --"
that's the thing I was
nervous about. "Do you think
Lorne would be okay
with that movie?"
And you go,
"Lorne is never going
to see your movie."
[ Laughter ]
-And that was not meant
to be cruel in any way.
-It wasn't cruel.
-Yeah.
-It was exactly what
I needed to hear.
-Yeah.
There's a lot of things
I've done, and Lorne is
the executive producer of
this show, that he has not seen.
-Oh, I'm sure.
-Yeah.
-And, but you haven't heard
from him yet, right?
You haven't heard from him
about "Don't Think Twice"?
-No, no.
I think that would have been --
Yeah, that would have been,
like, a great thing
if we got sued by "SNL"
in some ways.
It would have been
a big publicity thing.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We're much -- We're very low.
We're a little under the radar.
But, yeah, so I'm on
this new tour that we ran
into each other on the flight,
and then the pod --
this podcast, by the way,
is my own podcast.
-So, you --
When you were doing your --
When you put on your ear buds
to tune me out,
you were listening to yourself.
-Yeah, I mean, it's got
a lot of layers to it.
-Yeah.
-I've heard it --
-So, this is --
because your new show --
You're touring a show called
"The New One."
-And I don't like
to talk about it.
Like, in other words,
you know how, like,
your favorite movie is like --
My favorite movies this year are
like "Lady Bird" and
"The Big Sick" and "Get Out."
And like, what I like to do is,
to my friends I say,
"See this movie.
Don't see a trailer.
Don't see --
Don't read a review."
-Right.
-And I think that's a really
great gift you
can give somebody.
And so I don't --
With my new show,
I don't tell people
anything about it.
I just say, "If you like
the old albums, the old ones,
come see 'The New One'."
And so I have this five-episode
limited podcast where I talk to,
like, old friends --
John Mulaney,
Judd Apatow, Ira Glass --
about the old albums.
-That's great.
So, and when you talk
about them,
are they asking you questions
about your process
coming to jokes
or are you just --
-We just turn on
the microphones.
-You just turn on
Man what a --
what a tricky thing.
-It just flows.
[ Laughter ]
We just talk about it.
We just talk about it,
free-associate.
-And then you got nice --
I did not know you had
a podcast, but then Judd Apatow
posted this to let everybody
know you have a podcast.
-I never announced that
I was going to have it except
Judd Apatow wrote
on his Instagram,
"Doing a podcast
with Mike Birbiglia.
I just told him he has
green veggies stuck between
his teeth."
I thought that was really rude.
-Yeah.
-I'm at this age where my teeth,
they're just, like --
They're just like salad holders.
[ Laughter ]
-I just --
When I eat a salad,
50% goes in my belly,
40% in my teeth,
10% miscellaneous.
[ Laughter ]
-We're going to have to
track down that miscellaneous.
-Yeah, yeah.
Where's the miscellaneous?
-Thanks so much
for being here, buddy.
-Thank you.
-I can't wait for
"The New Show."
I liked the last five.
-Thank you so much.
-Mike Birbiglia, everybody!